emprisonnements tortures exécutions
trois mots terribles sur la couverture
d'un rapport d'amnesty international
qualifié de rapport de la honte car il
concerne vous allez le voir les
violences contre les enfants avec
d'autres organismes
amnesty international réclame une
convention internationale pour garantir
les droits des enfants est mis à l'index
bon nombre de pays l'afrique du sud
la birmanie l'iran l'irak le bangladesh
le sri lanka l'équateur la liste est
malheureusement loin d'être close
philippe gassot chaque année dans le
monde
14 millions d'enfants de moins de cinq
ans meurent de maladies ou de misère on
le savait plus ou moins mais savait-on
que délibérément des enfants étaient
torturés assassinés enlever aux quatre
coins du monde
le rapport d'amnesty est accablant
brutale voici ce qu'il dénonce
l'arrestation de 300 enfants
une trentaine sera tué certains auront
les yeux arrachés les petits torturé
devant leur mère pour les obliger à
parler c'était moins près des prisons
qui ont entendu les hurlements de
douleur
l'enfant supplicié pour semer la terreur
le nourrisson tué dans les bras de sa
mère le gamin enlevé que l'on ne reverra
plus hurlements dépôt vente et rires des
soldats les yeux des tortionnaires les
petits qu'on piétine
ce qui tombe faucher devant les
mitrailleuses ses membres secoué par
l'électricité
tout cela est dans le rapport tous ces
enfants martyrs qu'on a pu dénombrer
amnesty dénonce l'innocence et la
vulnérabilité ne protège pas contre les
abus de pouvoir les gouvernements
tous